this fascinating thing right now but
almonds is you're dealing with this
ballooning demand but you're also
dealing with supply that is struggling
yeah the crop was down seven percent
last year the u.s. makes about eighty
percent of all the crops that we
actually usually here in the US right
California and we have that horrible
horrible drought and almonds are very
water intensive so you've had that issue
the USDA actually expects production to
be down again this year so because of
that you have the double whammy and boom
you have those higher prices so there's
a huge cost Julie dolmens i do and i
flirt with almond butter a little bit
your peanut butter aficionado and I it
does it's true it's true but i do love
almond butter i went through that as
well the question is what does this do
on the retail level because you have
prices are so high you've seen other
companies like a smoker's coming in or
hain celestial they haven't been big
players in this market are now coming
into the market now I was talking to Ken
Shea of Bloomberg intelligence and
bloomberg industries I should say and he
was saying look it's really hard to
hedge these guys there is no futures
market for almonds like there is for
sale copper soybeans and corn you also
don't want to hedge too far out you
don't want to secure your supply one or
two years ago because it's quite
volatile so a lot of these guys go
direct to the source diamond the huge
player they've helped to set the price
level what happens when you get other
huge players that have big pockets
coming into the market alright of course
the insatiable demand from China to a
lot of people first got hooked on
almonds because it's a chinese new your
snack and then they decided that it's
actually much more healthy than some of
the other stuff and it also shows that
you're rich enough to afford it so let's
eat it year round there you go all right
oh really great point Alex you're gonna
stay with me here as we show you how
commodities prices have settled in your
trading we've got to start with crude
oil because we're talking about these
massive losses and it's interesting in
contrast to what you see in equities or
even the Treasury market stocks are down
what two-thirds of one percent eight
tenths of one percent and crude oil
intraday down seven point seven percent
yep Kim's this is an unbelievable slide
I want to put this into context that
show that's a two-day slides are is the
worst that we've seen since the end of
March and the daily slide it we see is
the most since november of 2014 here's
the kicker no one knows why and this is
where it gets really perplexing I've
literally
on the phone most of the day trying to
figure out what is going on with oil the
first thing is there was a technical
level at around 50 4.08 so that sort of
accelerated to the downside you can see
that hackles are like a 50-day moving
average 2012 or something like that
100-day moving average ah but
fundamentally oil is getting hit so much
harder than any other metal so it
doesn't make sense it cannot be a
risk-off trade because gold is not
surging if you're gonna put your money
into a safe haven commodity you put it
into gold well that's not playing out so
that rules the risk off trade if it's a
trade specifically related to china for
example because the stock market there
has really struggled you just had a
segment on that then you'd see copper
right even more because copper and iron
ore are really the proxies for China not
necessarily oil plus we've known about
their imports in in May for a while
we're waiting for the ones for June and
Iran yes we are about 24 hours away from
an agreement it's sort of the time
crunch will a deal get done some
analysts are much more optimistic but
it's not like they're going to offload
101 million barrels of oil tomorrow it's
going to take a while to get back so is
it just domestic supply and rig counts
and inventory numbers that were that
we're looking at a part of it is on
Thursday we got those rig numbers from
Baker huge that shows that there were 12
oil rigs actually added last week that
was the first time since last year so
that definitely could put sort of a pall
on the markets and you can see this
chart here is you have Baker Hughes oil
rig count trails the oilman rice by
about 20 weeks we've seen that up taken
oil there for those rigs are not far
behind but cities view had a great no
doubt saying you're dealing with supply
and demand that are affecting the market
it was supply for a while and now
there's demand problems as well
potential issues nobody really knows how
much China is actually using they're
importing but maybe just to fill their
their stock reserves not necessarily for
end-user demand and that's really the
question and we got maintenance coming
up and then the fourth quarter we
stopped driving and refiners go bye-bye
for business so what happens to Crete
market then